Whatever it is
[music]
Corps The
world's first aerial cavalry united by uniting the hearts and minds of soldiers who have achieved this after a long time and many sacrifices Rain
spears at the enemy's heart and
rush inside the gate  And with the powerful claws of the wiper, it's
perfect to keep the enemy at bay and open the gates to
avalanche the allies.
MUSIC]
That would have been us a nameless mercenary team
[MUSIC] [
MUSIC]
With weapons and ammunition, when we were about to give up,
God descended Abandoned
half-tracks and
old-fashioned 20mm  Machine gun
Thanks to this god, we survived and are here now Our fangs that
choose opponents and crush them Wolf is the origin of the name In just
a moment,
years of blood, sweat, tears, and a
huge budget
later
Please let me pray.